What we're gonna do now is we're going to play around with this
identity Matrix and we want
to use it. We want to use this identity Matrix.
Not to get the same Matrix back.
But to get a third Matrix where two
rows have either been swapped
around or they've been
manipulated somehow we have one two.
Negative 3 and then we have negative 3 negative
4. Okay, what we want to do is get this Matrix.
gradually into upper triangular form
so to
To do that we need this negative 3 to become zero.
Then we want to get this 2 to 0 and I'll
give this one to be equal to 0.
So these numbers?
We must get to be equal to 0.
Okay.
Using this identity Matrix or an adaptation of the identity Matrix.
Let me show you something. I'm going to copy this code.
And instead of having one one.
I'm going to go.
111 in the opposite direction, so I'm flipping the
axis.
Let's see. What happens when I do that.
I'm going to call this I underscore.
What happens when I do that?
Can you see what has happened?
the third row
Which is 215.
Is now at the top.
And the first row which is one two negative 3.
Is now at the bottom.
My point is the way we would.
Where we put a 1.
Is going to allow us to what performable operations
let me see if I can give you a very simple example.
A very simple I will come back this original one. So I'm
just going to create a very small Matrix. Let me call this.
M.
Just the two by two.
and let's make this to
and zero
and we'll make this one and one.
Okay, I want to
solve this Matrix
using
a modified version of the identity Matrix
Okay.
So we have one zero.
Zero one's across the diagonal obviously.
And like before if I were to multiply these matrices.
Not get back the same Matrix.
Okay, 2 0 1 1 2 0 1 1 now
if I want to solve this Matrix, I would have
to subtract 2.
from 1
so
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to go I'm going
to call this e e for elimination.
So this is the original Matrix right? Again, that's the identity Matrix.
one on the principal diagonals
if I set this to
negative 1
here's one way to read it.
Let me actually plug in more numbers in here just to expand just to
make this bigger. So you have some.
A better idea. I will make these zero down here.
Again, if I set this to zero, you have an identity Matrix.
if I set this to negative 1
Basically, here's one way to interpret it.
We're saying add to the second row.
the difference of the first row
add to the second row.
So whatever two is.
So imagine this is R1.
This would be R2. This would be R3. This is how you
you read the rows of an elimination Matrix.
Add to row two negative one of R1.
so basically multiply these by
negative 1
and add it to the second Matrix the second row.
I just want to make this part clear. So let me just add this
comment here.
So this is R1 R2 all
of these are R1 R2.
or 2 and everything here's R3. So basically
here's what I'm trying to say.
Okay.
Because elimination Matrix is a type
of encoding Matrix.
if you keep
What's across the diagonal to one so if I keep this
one I'm saying.
Keep Row 1 what it is.
If I make this one and the other zero.
I'm sick. Do not change Row 2 keep
R2 what it is.
And if I set these to zero.
And I make this one that I'm saying keep
R3 what it is.
if however I
make this one I'm saying keep R3
what it is.
But add R1 to it.
So it's like I'm activating rule one.
Row one will be added to
Row three
so for example
Let me make this zero again.
Okay. Once again, we will get the same Matrix.
But I try to get across this idea that we
can play around with this identity Matrix to
eliminate.
And get to the upper triangle.
So let's return to the above example.
And do this again? Okay. I'm going to go back
to the identity Matrix.
Set these.
to 0
okay.
I'll do one example.
When I get to the second the third
elimination matrices, you should get the idea. Okay.
So if I run this now, I'm going to get the I say Matrix.
So one two negative three, we want to negative 3.
Negative. Okay. I hope you can see they're all the
same. Okay. Now I'm going to make this my first elimination Matrix.
To get to my first elimination Matrix. I need to get rid of minus three.
I need this to become a zero.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to create my first elimination Matrix.
This will be a modification of the identity Matrix.
So to get rid of this.
Negative 3 I need to multiply Row
1 by 3.
So this will become 3. This will become 6. This will become negative 9
and then add this row.
to the second row
because three plus negative three they cancel each other and we get
to zero.
So I'm going to go.
negative 3
Okay.
And then I'm going to multiply together.
So I'm going to multiply my first elimination Matrix.
times a
Okay.
It's supposed to be negative 3 or 3.
It's supposed to be 3.
So you see here?
Our first row is the same.
Our third row is the same but now we have
discarded the leading negative 3
in the second row.
That's my first elimination Matrix.
and my so I will now reassign a
to this evaluation
Okay, so my a has been updated.